wow it's incredible having watched Tom
Scott provide amazing content for a
decade to now see him create the model
for YouTubers to exit with Grace from
this platform he's going to slow down
his schedule and focus on tailoring
content to himself and not to the
increasingly frantic demands of an
algorithm this decision has been met
with universal praise and shows that
viewers clearly prefer when an artist is
true to themsel and pursue YouTube with
passion rather than a sense of corporate
obligation is probably something to
learn from all
this hey guys welcome back to episode
8,000 of I stopped caring 3 years ago
written and edited by someone else